here is what Obama said about his sexual
orientation in regard to homosexuality I
must say that I believe this is an
attempt to remove oneself from the
present a refusal perhaps to perpetuate
the endless farce of Earthly life
you see I make love to men daily but in
the imagination
okay this is a profound statement I
think that social conservatives are a
little too harsh here because a lot of
them want to kind of make fun of Obama
for for appearing to be a little bit
light in the loafers but
what he's saying is I have homosexual
desires and I'm suppressing them what's
he supposed to do isn't that good isn't
that what the social conservatives want